here's some sanity for you this is uh
the legendary by the way who just turned
93 years young just a few days ago I
think on June 27th if I'm not mistaken
Thomas Soule who actually still
technically is at Stanford and when he
was at Stanford for the majority of his
career Stanford was a somewhat
functional University but this is Thomas
sold about a decade or so ago uh
wrecking absolutely wrecking affirmative
action with Tucker Carlson
I think you often hear people say well
affirmative action may be unfair but
it's helped a lot of people you buy that
it may have helped some people but on
net balance I don't believe it has
there's a marvelous study done showing
that when they banned affirmative action
in California uh University of
California system blacks began to uh
graduate at a much higher rate than
before graduate with much higher grade
point average graduated in subjects like
math and Engineering to a far greater
extent than before because now the
students went to those particular parts
of the University system that fitted
their particular academic preparation
and they graduated before you know you
could flunk out of Berkeley or UCLA
which does you no good now you can
graduate from Davis or Santa Cruz and go
on to a career
isn't that something if you put people
at schools that they should be in that
match up with their skills with their
work ethic with what the sum totality of
what they are at that ripe age 16 17 and
you put them in a school that can help
that flourish you don't just Elevate
them to a school that can't help them
flourish just because of the color of
their skin that they actually will do
better in life isn't that something and
if you do that you also don't have to
discriminate against those pesky Asians
and white people who work real hard
[Music]